there's droppin the mic and then there's
that meghan trainor last night on The
Tonight Show I just want you to take one
more look at it you see the ankles get
shaky in those heels and then well the
floor is the next stop after that I'm so
feeling her pain right now and I still
love her right now and that is where she
stayed lying on her back with Jimmy
Fallon and that again that's why we love
her so much as they're so feature lazy
found out Megan keeps it real I was
makin we do we do she's all about
keeping it real to rejecting Photoshop
by pulling a music video earlier this
week when her waist was altered I had a
bomb weigh sign I don't know why they
didn't like my waist and now this I've
never done a photo shoot with my arms
out
I don't feel pale I'm insecure about
them she's putting it all out there once
again making sure her fans know it's the
real Megan on this month's cover of
Seventeen magazine everyone in the room
was like she's dope jacking off
Megan's increased confidence isn't all
that has changed since we met her two
years ago
back then she was on a tight budget I
haven't seen the money is so I'm not
rich yet so I can't be like Vegas here
we come
now she's buying brand new digs
Riley moving into a new house as more
space big girl house yeah bigger like at
my first house ever I'm moving in with
my two brothers and my besties and we
all get our own rooms that's like a new
thing for us now while she still has
roommates
this girl's also got a Grammy oh yeah
were you keeping it it was next my bed
and then I moved it over to my dresser
sit I can look at it and be in spice
right in my face like this class I just
love being inspired while I get like my
pants you know I love her honesty to the
Grammys right there Yeah right there put
a clothes girl I'm just warning that
she's gonna actually wear heels when she
performs her head no at the Billboard
Music Awards make the 22nd on ABC I
think she should come out barefoot